zana allée commence à les y aller j'ai
commencé à les armer vous voilà
attention réfléchissez à réfléchissent
et oui elle est réfléchie c'était
marrant toi
attention attention attention et non
mais non à moi à moi dès qu'il est bête
[Applaudissements]
m
vous avez rien compris j'ai vu mais la
triche et on peut pas tricher je n'ai
jamais alors j'ai vu des mauvais jeux la
merde évolué comme bernard montiel
j'ai maintenant c'est bon c'est bon
c'est bon c'est bon c'est mon portable
voilà merci au revoir merci je me sens
pas seule à tous et pour finir la
séquence le méta mais c'est comme un
mauvais élève vous savez à l'école qui
fait exprès des mains de marc est bon
pour partir un polype unis dont alors
alors on y va
merci voilà c'est fait ça bien qu'elle
avait accepté d'être très très bel hôtel
sa très belle tenue bravo pour le père
noël est ce que vous êtes prêts allez
aller 3-1 les y aller a dévoilé les
images y aller si un très bon lancer de
donetsk
une réplique guillaume genton ensuite
nous avons attention déjà dû aligner
pour rire de genton pas mal est bloqué a
été bloqué à son attention attention
allez-y la paix si ces mamies répétition
pas trop longtemps plume amis quand même
un bon assistant sur ce il a attend
comme une conne comptait bien compter
ses quatrains ces quatre pions quatre
pions aligner attention ouais pas mal
pas mal attention attention attention il
répétait pour l'instant le match est
parfaitement équilibré c'est un duel de
titans et d'anti temps il ya dit merci à
qui
attention attention attention mais non
mais non il a fait une grosse erreur
magnon pourquoi vous n'avez pas regardé
jeu que j'avais vu perdre bien fait
allez-y regardez bien
[Musique]
je me rappelle que je souffre d'aidé du
des loges oculaires ont besoin de prix
n'est pas monsieur coué très jeunes
ivoiriens merci bravo isabelle chésa
suis très content bord vous pouvez
rester là isabelle vallée à les imiter
figurines et se qualifie face à gilles
verdez conservatif annie pas plutôt bien
sa main j'ai de la chance vous allez
m'affronter dans cette épreuve pour
c'est que c'est qui le patron alors vu
mon état oculaire regarder comment je
vois elle et moi c'est moi je vois là
moi je vois comme ça fabricants d'écrans
l'arrivée cherche une excuse si le bras
c'est bien je vous rappelle on met homes
et des jeeps dépit de notes celui que
nadine 4 horizontales verticales ou en
événements remporte la partie se
qualifie pour la phase leur entraîneur
c'est très clair à nos yeux mais pas
laisser partir alors zélandais alors que
commencer allez-y honneur aux dames
nous honorons david r je pouvais tout je
veux dire au delà
bah oui mais dans ces cas-là bail dans
ces cas là vous faites ce que vous
voulez je blogue mahjoub la grille et là
je voudrais donc en fait c'est
maintenant le principe est simple vous
êtes benjamin moi je vous redonne oui
oui mais au bout d'un moment il faut
attaquer alors attaqué l'équipe moi je
moi y aller moi ce que je vais faire
garder je gère ça comme ça je vais vous
rob lowe kébila là on pourrait croire
on pourrait croire que je n'ai pas vu
parce que je vois rien que mes yeux mais
les anglais y en a trois donc est ce que
je fais je bloque sur wii et wii
très bien et là attention attention
danger attention danger parce que là si
je fais pas si je fais pas et je joue
mal
bim bam bam mme mba même qu'est ce qu'il
peut se passer à une catastrophe donc je
fais ça baffes et là vous êtes mal et
oui eh ben non
là on pourrait croire que j'ai pas vu
mais on pourrait croire il est prévu
mais comme je vois très bien au be-bop
je vois j'ai goûté oui attention parce
que là ça sent le piège
ça sent le piège vous le dis je vous ai
enserré dans les camps mais non mais non
vous pensez que je n'ai pas vu mais rien
de mon oeil avait demandé comme isabelle
bim jouer à gauche
biba à plat et voilà forcément
et là c'est compliqué hélas ces combinés
mais aussi comme ans de scène
et attention et bim bam et je fais bim
bam boum
elle est
c'est vrai
ok les besoins des déplacés dépasser
leur rivalité a pas danger donc vous
mettre la merci beaucoup
les filles attention c'est important
c'est qui le patron pour l'instant
monsieur pernikoff lui est qualifié
directement
ah oui il est devant un patron il est ni
des mieux que cyril hanouna oui c'est
pas trop le sait le alors je ne sais pas
encore si c'est bien mon avis de cette
enquête beaucoup laissé le principe
beaucoup le 6e jeu question-là suis prêt
donald horizontal vertical est ok on
réfléchit on se concentre jours voilà on
regarde bim bam boum c'est clair c'est
ok alesi a les histoires d'amour hosono
honneur aux femmes quatre au c allez-y
alors alors on n'est pas oubliée petits
conseils de toujours tout doucement qui
est bousculé prenez votre temps prenez
votre réfléchissez bah oui attention
attention attention a mis à mal un
contre de géraldine
e
oui attention attention qu'elle y
réfléchisse ne jouais pas trop vite
qu'ils ne le sait ça fuse ça pue chez
vous attention pour l'instant pour
l'instant c'est a pour l'instant c'est
un match et oui regardez
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de ce jeu lors des poussées ses martyrs
a dit non mais alors en moins d'atouts
pour le dire vous savez je trouve je
voulais didier c'est vrai mais à la des
enfants elle joue avec ses enfants
délocalisent alors je sais pas si sa
cachette 20 kms effacer une question
d'enfants ou une question de
concentration
je pense que c'est la concentration je
pense aussi était ébloui par votre
beauté pour célébrer parce que kanye ce
week end et ce canapé ce week-end à la
fêter je suis pas la même année c'est
normal ça arrive c'est beaucoup plus
long les prêts 3-2 si j'arrivais à
l'ailé
allez-y tous les cols rouges on
réfléchit on réfléchit pour l'instant on
l'a pour l'instant ça va
bah voilà
attaque de gémir death
contré par madame marie ni bosque bernès
oui pas mal révèle ne jouais pas trop
vite servez-vous notre cerveau ou ce
qu'il en reste
attention attention
pas mal pas mal pas mal ça a pas mal
attention attention oui c'est est assez
équilibré pour l'instant attention
gilles et j'ai mal hein ouais j'ai mes
enseignants réfléchissent et
réfléchissez y réfléchissez audi dont je
ne vois rien le noir chair c'est naturel
pour moi
allez-y adhésif allait bien sûr allez-y
pour l'instant pour l'instant on va pas
se mentir il avait les mieux partis que
gilles
mais bon j'ai d'abord oui attention jean
oublie pas chez vous trouvez le gagnant
contre les féroé kempé peut-être la
tablette tactile pour vous alors il
avait lé pa maryse avait pas mal
attention isabelle attention mais non
c'est pas c'est pas gagné mais non mais
non mais non ces quatre pions à la suite
et mamies ne se laisse pas faire
attention aux libyens bien comprise il
bravo ne se complaît c'est spectaculaire
c'est spectaculaire attend à les
attentions elle est forte il avait
travaillé très fort comme quoi
encore une fois comme quoi justement
attention certains sont gilles soyez bon
gilles soyez bon attention aquiba encore
incontrol isabelle à ça peut durer
longtemps
c'est un jeu qu'elle a beaucoup a
indiqué madame morini-bosc 1c attention
attention peut-être peut-être peut-être
peut-être peut-être gêné rester
concentré et voilà nos examens gagné
bras au gym
oui mais voilà j'avoue que franchement
gagné ce jeu sans rien voir et sans rien
comprendre inapte est un véritable exode
segers et beaucoup j'étais mesures
possibles alors honneur aux femmes alors
honneur aux femmes
oui je vais poser ma baguette du coup se
tailla les allées du hall of fame
attention c'est parti
ok moi j'ai une technique c'est que je
joue assez dispersées oui d'accord
vim oui c'est malin enfin je crée un
petit peu le jeu créé un petit peu
l'espace est une bonne idée
c'est une façon de faire là surtout pas
jouer là pour parfaire la diagonale mais
en revanche je joue la semag ac madoff
savait c'est malin et là hop c'est pas
mal attention attention là je vais vous
montrer ici la jama
je suis vraiment aider mais je suis
vraiment très mauvaise d'être condamné
ah oui mais je suis déçue déçue déçue
c'est vrai qu'on était content d'eux m'a
mis un à bernis bien négoce c'est pas
des clubs bienvenue monsieur banny kof
venez tous restés là isabel celaa mais
puisque je pense qu'à mon avis isabelle
d'isabel allende banon s'est passé je
voulais pas bien vu de loin avaient
confondu ce sera donc la première petite
finale
parce que bon je pense que le pack on va
descendre un peu plus tard d'accord très
bien joué entre ga entre gilbert d'eps
entre les gravats des cov et forcément
serrée les de la basse alors les mains
vous avez compris
allez on lui faisait partie il ne veut
pas trop ne pas trop vêtus de blanc je
veux pas trop vite attention attention
attention un contrat de gilles verdez
très bien très très bien ensuite nous
avons quoi
attention une attaque une attaque de une
attaque de gérald et nous attention j'ai
alors fait bien parce que géraldine jean
gaye malgré lui
c'est bien les techniques essayées de
l'enpc la vérité pour l'instant c'est
pas mal pour l'instant ça se passe pas
trop mal attention gide l'avait jugé
ah bah tiens cyril hanouna et là je suis
lent spectateurs le trafic d'armes à
rester spectateur alors c'est pour pas
mal ça va regarder ça pendant dix heures
ça se passe pas mal
attention gilles attention aux îles
ayala la contrée hier à l'ena contre et
c'est normal c'est pas mal c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal attention
j'ai réfléchi c'est arrivé à un milliard
est prêt à livrer les i allez-y voit pas
mal et la tête de gilles attention
attention contre attaque de géraldine
n'importe quoi en fait
comment je me bats je me disais je
attention attention le baril à yaya
attention aux attentes se passe au
attention à la tension attention non
merci
attention et s'il a gagné mais n'y a pas
gagné
et s'il va quand même y aller lui c'est
incroyable la taille a pas compris
n'allez pas vous engueuler pas ces gels
à l'origine
enfin mais non enfin gilles et gilles
mégi le si gilles enfants gilles
sigillée pas les yeux en face des trous
gilles enfin
mais l'embellie des attentions mais non
oui bah oui aval qui nous regarde là là
là là en bas en bas attention maintenant
il n'y avait pas de solution à ces
contributions ya pas de solution il faut
pas il faut voir plus tard maintenant
l'impôt et n'importe quoi mais non c'est
le pire qui pouvait à la la c'est pas
possible et septembre réfléchir c'est
terminé c'est terminé ma fille
[Applaudissements]
avec des bras
je hais le coup à manger et je suis
content croyable troyat merci a toi d
heure qu'est ce mois vers ben matin vers
la bonde égide non mais nord c'est
nicolas pernikoff je me souviens alors
ça ça dépend si vous êtes le patron le
petit patron c'est lui c'est lui d'abord
séduit d'abord donc voix c'est le grand
patron à moi à moi je regarde pour
l'instant pour garder j'ai été détrônée
d'accord c'est nicolas pernikoff j'ai
commencé comme l'avait fait n'importe
quoi laisser des plus importantes à
lévis je ne vais pas trop vite
réfléchissez clos cavale attention voilà
c'est bien
il connaît très rapide doit pas mal pas
mal pas mal pas mal n'est pas mal
d'attention réfléchissez gilles épaissir
ou n'importe comment
il est mauvais
surtout pas chez nous on fait déjà mais
n'ont ainsi à l'aider surtout pas là ce
qu'on fait alors ses extravagances et il
sert à rien seul et que tu viens de metz
a bien joué un contrat qu il
conviendrait bien attention à la sasson
à sa saga aïe aïe aïe aïe
mais oui civile russe attend ça sent le
roussi là ça sent le roussi
mais pas du tout il ya au carreau si oui
c'était les six mois et demi comme je la
sens cosy à oka aussi mais c'est dur
aussi là il m'arrive aussi deuxième
année vous le cul là c'est vrai mais
n'importe quoi mais non mais non mais
oui mais nicolas gauche en bas à gauche
est allé dit enfin à jouer bien jouer le
chien il a très bien joué
attention attention
[Applaudissements]
mais attention et non attendez qui sous
protêt à l'aider
est-ce qu'il a fallu aulas il a ripé il
arrivé au lycée
voilà bien monter la côte à côte à côte
et mènera mais la whey mais oui
[Applaudissements]